welcome to another installment of the
Android developer relations office hours
I'm Sparky and I'm also joined by my
colleagues Nick and Peter in the lemon
on this and we are here to discuss any
and all issues related to Android
development so let's start by welcoming
people on the air and asked you have any
questions for us today hey hey Sparky
I've got one for you okay when i've been
using loaders and the cursor loader
seems to be orientated towards using a
content provider is there any reason
that people should focus on using a
content provider or is using direct
queries to the databases are packing for
loader considered okay as well that
depends where you ask that there's
actually divided opinions inside of
general I would say if it works go for
it if you if you think it's going to
make your life a lot easier to do direct
database access in your loader go ahead
but I think all the samples that your
friend are probably going to be oriented
around I'm doing the content provider
route and apart from apart from sort of
a certain amount of boilerplate code
that you have to write I'll see a really
important reason about to go that way
cool thanks I've got the question next
you will need the to do it to waste
either the to a slider I see nothing in
the documentation about that I noticed
that there's only there's basically only
two flags there's like orientation
horizontal orientation Bertha I didn't
see anything about left to right or
right to left so yeah I would say you
know play over play around with it and
see if you can figure anything out for
me go get the get the android OS
platform source code off of off of the
internet see how it's implemented and
let us know it fine thanks hey up give
it a go
you cannot say it's only girls left to
life right there's no way to switch the
I'm the provider I haven't mess around
with with these sliders myself all I can
say is when I lived in the documentation
I didn't see anything at all about ionic
directional and horizontal versus
vertical because they want to prevent it
like you know Tuesday to set a minimum
in the maximum an option and we want the
user to be able to be able to control
what the best a lot to way slider
because that's the way they was to it I
suppose there's nothing stopping you
from implementing your own custom
control you know do something
interesting with the viewpager perhaps
for know where a dialogue you know
implement uh like make a gesture
detector and just display a dialogue on
a gesture or something like that that's
there since equal ooh yeah oh okay
because I tried the google and google
there's any help a lot of this topic I
haven't certainly be the first to tell
you not to reinvent the wheel if you
don't have to okay then that's it for me
pull out plated long I'm going for Peter
he's busy typing away there and has he
seen any common feature requests or
things from the geyser and africa such
as I requested to limit the amount of
data that's pulled down give our
networks there on that horse movie Nick
are you guys unit just Peter talking we
can barely hear you Peter well we're
straightening know we've also just then
joined by no on hi how are you do you
have a question where is known do you
want to have asked
question about Android build oh no not
learn any music oh yes he Oh Peter I
turning that time okay good right so
what I was saying about pops on and
Africa generally the questions about
bandwidth fonts the terms of limiting
they don't the Android or the
application site a lot of that is
obviously dependent on what people are
trying to be over the Internet for
example i'm looking at Stack Overflow
stuff and they generally they used gzip
to compress their streets no api most
submissions that I get are what is and
what is Google doing to improve the
situation and I'll soon can we get
better devices those are the kind of
questions i get from sub-saharan africa
but i'm generally came to ask that we
should do anything about limiting the
data I think that's generally an
infrastructure a ship Google's already
doing a lot in terms of its
infrastructure on the access site to
optimize these things so that's probably
the way we're going to look at helping
the situation go so yep thank me so no
I'm welcome to the show would you like
to ask a question about android
development
yeah I speak I think you'll meet it if
you can't talk if you're in a noisy
environment feel free to ask your
question in the chat no while we then
move on and take a question from the
moderator we still have a few left over
from last week see what's the best way
to give access to a paid app to select
people without them name on thinking
something along lines of gift codes for
testers that they don't have to pay but
still get the updates from google play
well yeah gift codes is a cool idea
unfortunately we don't have gift codes
at this time but you could always make
an app free to download and they have
some sort of server based authentication
that kind of you know implement your own
whitelisting and let the users unlock
the the functionality that way that's
kind of the best idea I can come up with
what about you other guys any thoughts
on that how to how to give free access
to paid apps to selected users best way
is really to get them to buy an
application send you the check out order
ID Andrew Thunder unfortunately it's not
great workflow but you know if you want
to send out to a few reviewers or
something that way its way to look
around it that's about right now okay
next person from our reader developers
are asking for the best practice ways to
implement list adapters I would love to
see a really good tutorial on the
resources which shows the best way to do
it what would you guys recommend so yeah
I've been feeling that this probably
time for us to come up with a really
really good grounding and how to do list
adapters because I see this bust on a
whole line and stack overflow there are
a lot of tutorials out there they I
haven't I haven't visited most of them
myself they're just too many but my my
current go to favorite is is fragment
layout
from the comp at for demo because it's
it uses the list fragment and it also um
you know it's super super simple and it
has everything you need in one source
code file that's compatible all the way
back to donut so that's that's my go-to
but maybe you guys can offer your own
your own favorites for what do you use
for a template for list adapter and I
used a toy that shows you how to use the
database you know i mean it database
inside your left so we have a good like
just a simple thing and it's like yes
say for like a catalyst to show
countries and stuff like that hmm so
that dancing a hella list you right call
me drew yes that's a good one you know
that'sthat's in in the developer android
com /resources tutorials section yes and
it's very simple because it's the very
basic so it's very easy to understand
how without to use it maybe we should
post a link to that if you have it i
leave my things just roll my own every
time I write one it's just you know
extend based adapter place get view to a
little and you hold a pattern pretty
simple stuff I tend to find a lot of the
time that the ones that are included
such as resource cursor adapter things
like that tend to cover a lot of what I
need I find it very rare i actually need
to go roll my own I've been times been
tempted to roll my own and then had
another look at what's available and
found something useful there because
there seemed to be an awful lot of them
built into the framework yeah
updating well well thanks for your
suggestions since there's nobody else in
the chat I want to the next runner in
inland name of one of the next question
in moderator let's see Eric rajala
belfius says we on let's think they
visit that it really the best resource
working this is that people i/o talk two
years ago viro monkey their world list
you I mean that really goes through all
the fundamentals of everything you need
to know about working with less so that
is your kind of go to place a world of
whiskey so I started carry on what plus
wonder what Nick said anything that ever
came from Romania is worth your time
okay so arrogant Philly says we're
struggling to implement a gallery that
looks nice on a site word we suspect
it's a problem on parole as you I skin
it looks great on all the other tablets
any tips on dealing with manufacturer
skins and the best answer that I can
come up with is either use hollow as
your theme or create your own theme but
inherit from hollow because the
holographic theme is one that
manufacturers are not allowed to modify
so it needs to have a non starting point
and it may not look and it's natural on
you know in the context of all the other
applications on that particular device
which may be using for example the
device default theme but at least it'll
look the same on every device that
you're deployed on my guess is sort of
the question is do you want to look like
all the other apps or anyone all of your
instances to look the same if you want
everything of your solo the same then
inherit the mall all right this next
question from moderator what is the
current state and future plan for native
vector graphics supports part of the
under graphics you I well we don't
speculate on things that haven't been
announced so I would say we have nothing
to say that data vector graphics
yeah it on set next question is it
possible to build a file content
provider to access files on an ftp
server I would say yes you can build a
content provider that's backed by an ftp
server but your latency would probably
be pretty bad but other than that
technically there's no reason I could do
it well we're just doing this on the
Hangout moisture no Moshe Moshe hi
welcome to the Hangout do you have a
question about android development if
you made your haiku weekend because
you're not a quiet environment or
something for free to type your question
in chat or in the industry is it ducking
suspect of it's a bit Bennifer they can
hear us we see in your office now is
they summer is a friend of mine so do
you even know yes here you know yes I
thought the question about the action
bar hey hey just show I just show the
Sherlock action Val and I would like to
add it to my project I don't know why
but I can I try to add it and it seems
like wait they will search for the arrow
he seems to me that they like the
minimum SDK the target SDK it's not a
competitive a with this version can you
explain me a bit about the minimum SDK
the target SDK what their meanings also
ugly and the minimum SDK
actionbarsherlock is a TI 7 that right
everyone it's like that's right to me
that's for the actual application itself
but if he's building actionbarsherlock
as a separate library project that needs
to be up i think at 15 for that but
specific project then his main app can
be at seven so the build version are you
talking about the targets DK different
things like um there's what you can do
is you can have actionbarsherlock as a
separate project under Eclipse and the
separate actionbarsherlock project needs
to be 15 but the app may nap project can
be down as low as seven I'm not sure
whether that's the way he's doing it
whether that's the problem is
encountering that make sense mushy and
so I mr. under the action bar she
learned a little bit and I just started
by building the samples that came
actionbarsherlock and sort of progressed
from there on I took it and sort of
retro actively applied it to some of the
demos from from the from the API demos
are like the comp at versions may API
demos and dead own State worked all
right for me I have a I have a those
those those code that source code is
online I'll show you the language since
I find it you belong and yes thank you
very much and they would like to say
that the Eclipse doesn't recognize the
sum of the package in the classes you
are supposed to do I just download it
and load the import the project into my
clips he doesn't recognize a lot of the
files what do you have with your minimum
SDK or the target SDK version in the adt
drop out drop em it's a ginger but isn't
its motion this is what it said 2.3 like
the lowest version that you use to point
to point o ok if you've downloaded
actionbarsherlock and it's that project
you're having a problem with you'll need
to use for point no point 3
and you should find that will find the
packages at the actionbarsherlock
project references okay thank you so I
found my sample code if you go to
code.google.com / p / Sherlock dash demo
this is a little sample that I hacked up
they I thought me at work wild is that
it use it back but every with the
together with the API demos sample that
mashes up the the viewpager and the the
tabs so this uses basically native
action bar tabs in combination of the
viewpager in combination with
actionbarsherlock that's that's in a
nutshell we thought it had posted
basically none of the code was written
by me I just adapted its little work
together so that's that's code google
com / e / Sherlock dash demo we've just
been joined by I'm rom welcome you have
a question about android development yes
I do hey I ask this in the moderator
also but if you can answer me here
that's great on what was your question
about the alert dialog how to make a
custom class subclass of our dialogue
that will look like Alex dialogue but
with custom content view and into the
one it says the end of the first page i
think it was in the moment is that on
the eim a moderator erza one of the
other moderators also i think it was
labeled a u.s. one how can I know if you
if it's in the moderator that was linked
from the announcement this hangout okay
so in any case i will ask here ok mr.
I have a subclass of alert dialog that
will show a list of the available Wi-Fi
networks in range and I want the user to
pick one and then to return the result
to the some activity now when I searched
either the custom view or the view
itself of the of the alert dialog it
just replaces the whole the whole view
and I don't get the title or the icon or
the frame so my question is how do i get
the alert dialog look with my costume
content view so you can't just do like
just a custom you for the list item
itself no because the other that myself
class is also responsible for listening
to this counter results of the Wi-Fi
manager and updating the list as they
come so it has to be a subclass a
specific cell plus the father of a log
and this is the reason why I can't use
the alert dialog builder so I can just
give it a custom list view or something
like that it has to be my sub class
could this be a good opportunity to use
a dialog fragment and the fragment
framework no I don't do hmm they're like
Activision and I'm thinking I'm thinking
uh it's yeah I I just don't know whether
the framework actually does what you
need as one of its built-in widgets or
if you just need to kind of all your own
I don't know off the top of my head you
know I would say if none of us noticed
right off the top of our head then your
best recourse is probably to post a
question in new stack overflow and let
the expert community longer there was a
long did but I got no good answer yet
okay can you yeah you can
you can give us the back tank overflow
lengthen then I'll try to take a look at
it next day or two okay I'll do that do
you know if I'll their dialogue even
intended to be used without the builder
or okay if I can i create my own we've
put the constructor and presenting
myself or should i use only the builder
that i don't know i would say use the
Builder if you can but you know again a
lot of these things are conveniences to
try to to optimize the common case and
if your case is a special case then
you're just because you can't use
something like a builder doesn't mean
it's necessarily wrong for you to use
you know more direct access to the more
item i myself i used i know that without
the bigger ones what they did is I take
the day off index immense and then use
the method called sets they also
constantly kind of mistaken and just put
in the link to their layouts and I can
just build it to del X del L dialogue
and it looked like other dollar yes it
looks like him a little it up
like a nominal dialogue and then they
black the rest of the skin like in the
hollows I look okay so if you could
answer my question stuck on hold up
would be great okay sounds like you two
should take it offline who else is in a
call oh we've been joined by a martini
and group rice any any questions about
android development from youtube ok who
is hard at work he says even though he's
listening to us or need you have a
question about android development that
you'd like to ask
and yet we see we have one question from
the moderator we did that one last week
is there an easy way to test the life
saith / fragment just like the activity
in a test case um well not that I know
of the damn fragments are hosted by
activities so so basically you just have
to I've been quite a region through the
activity blends it and see I'm finding
an instrument like an action send
multiple you just die out what's the
reason we are not covering concoctions
of multiple this world so yeah the
framework is not always perfectly
orthogonal if it's something that
sometimes bring your features get a rise
out of these of particular applications
that are being implemented in the
framework and so the now and this sort
of sort of API is created as needed i
don't know if that was the case here or
it's just the way it happened to me um
yeah and there are some tour there's
some tutorials where people have done
something like that for instance and if
you go to the moderator you can see the
links like tears viccus connie wordpress
com / 2011 720 and request him image
gallery with checkbox in a grid to
select multiple it's a awfully long URL
but if you go into the moderator you can
just click on the link so yeah you know
i could put it as a feature
the West might have done so i don't
remember i think i did but yeah
sometimes sometimes the framework just
doesn't cover every air ever use case no
not even always be the ones so that's
minus at that what do you guys think any
any thoughts from from nigga peter allen
those actions say multiple not gone can
you possibly pick a bucket re could do
using that yeah it basically Jesus
trying to do like a multi gallery picker
and try to and try to send them all okay
because there isn't actually say
multiple question um he I so let me do
something yes that the writer talks
about power sent multiple is there and
what he wants is pick multiple yeah
please like their the reciprocal action
sure I'll just wondering if there's no
waving they gave you used to send
multiple to actually get the same
functionality um or you could then just
try and you know get some support for
multiple apps to support your own pic
multiple action so if you could register
the pic mods full-on open intense that
all or somewhere like that and try and
petition developers of other gallery
such apps to support the intent there's
no reason what I mean obviously be great
if it was built in but you know we can
suggest as a feature but do remember
like them open in tensile school mom yes
this big magic about the intense listed
in that one there just constant stream
doing you just need to get enough people
to converge around the same actions and
verbs and saying like meta data types
and magic can happen I will concede
though that it's I think it's pretty
hard to get a lot of momentum behind a
third-party intent I'm you know it's
great if you can do it and I'm all for
it but but
sometimes you just do need a little bit
of an extra push from the Advocate from
their framework to its through the
things like there's ever crossing have
done it with this action scan right it's
not impossible it's just you need to be
really proactive with good support you
know really good documentation of your
intense and and find like office and
really useful functionality and
hopefully it will all come there is
always of course if it is a really
really useful intent the possibility of
submitting it to the android open source
project and that way you can't wriggle
through into future versions if it gets
the right amount of backing the answer
yeah one excellent well I see that Oren
has joined us in the Hangout Goren you
have a question for us Oren is typing
okay so while he's taping perhaps I will
want my ex moderator question on who
would you recommend 90 implement line
patches in your application assets the
UI designer or the developer this is a
google well i would say designer all the
way because as a developer my artistic
skills suck wait you think maybe well i
think i said a case by case it tends how
comfortable your designer is where you
know code concepts and so on hopefully
there should be ok i've worked on
projects where the designers deliver the
nine patches they completely mucked up
with stretching and scaling areas and
that's been great I never places
designers than what you want to think my
kind of thing and it developers have to
figure out so I think it comes down to
the case by case of your team long ago I
volunteer effort in you know an MMO and
I would say you know we meet we had a
term there we call it programmer art
programmer art is images that the the
decoders act up just to kind of make
something work until the artist could
actually get to it and sometimes you
programmer
we got out into the game and you can
always tell when when landscape basis or
moms were assembled by the developers as
opposed to buy the artists I mean I
developed a couple months myself just
using tile sprite graphics and you know
I thought they look pretty okay and then
an artist you know it's like stun a date
on it buddy Hance is pretty alright not
an artist would come along two hours
he'd get something that just blew away
everything that I had done so now I'm a
big fan of I'm a big fan of letting the
artists to do a lot of designers seem to
like the idea that once you've taught
them about nine patch durables they if
they're free lines designers
particularly they can then go on and say
look I know about this stuff you're
writing an Android app I can design it
specifically for that platform sites
it's a skill that designers can pick up
and sometimes it's actually worth a
designer taking the time to to get
familiar with it now generally designers
a few like a safe the door they'll grab
these things and run with it and as a
rule i mean if i have a designer handy i
would power handed a perfect arrangement
because after all that's what they do
you exit such a failure well and we can
take a look at Warren's question he
wants to know how do i debug any cake
hold on window because i don't find any
official tutorials i don't think there
are too many official tutorials on any k
danielle dan gave some talks in the last
year or two about any cave and some of
those covered debugging I don't mess
around much of NDK myself because I'm
not like sort of SDK focused but maybe
if I recall most of most of the Commons
revolved around attaching windows
debuggers to the C library debugging
that Alice as a native windows libraries
basically use eclipse to debug the java
stuff you know the dalek stuff and use a
windows debugger debug to see stuff
that's that was my recollection
essentially you want to be running ddb
so there is
on your phone and then it's yes this
debugging overdue TV connection as I'm
standing but I think in the latest
preview release of them ADT ATT 20 this
and beginnings of ndk debug support
coming up in so you might want to jump
over to tools that android com and we
know from the latest announcements and
see what's going on there they'll help
you I hadn't really had transferred over
myself yet but i think this and learn
what starting to come out there and
there's a link in the chat thing clock
awesome and there's also a couple of
questions being asked in the deeper
spread so I thought we could pop circle
back and pick those up as well that's
courses on men so David Scott up who's
also just joined the chat it would you
want to ask your question live rather
than me reading it out I'm this is an
aquarium um i thi think that they Mike
okay let me read out what you worked in
there in the first place it's been long
and question about screen size
qualifiers I want to be able to filter
my appt the devices were certain screen
resolution and I realized planned it the
exact same position so you mean you want
it to only show up the steps and screen
sizes okay yes I don't it's not a good
idea to focus on the pixel cam if you
really want to build more physical sizes
while you sucking out I read the rest
expecting says what I want is a filter
what I want to build sport is 7-inch
tablets and larger but also for
high-risk phones like galaxy nexusgalaxy
no I also wanted to fact this basketball
for 2.2 possible any idea is the best
practice for this supports prints so
compatible screens is your only option
at the moment I'm stream Lee hesitant
recommend it because it's a pretty blunt
tool
but if you look at the compatible
screens and element in your manifest
that lets you opt in to screen size and
density combinations so you could opt in
to say I only want my apt to be
available to an XLR screens with these
densities and normal sized screens only
with state X HTTP I resolution so you
can do that again I'm going to warn you
and say please don't do that okay
basically you will see your kind of
opting into certain configurations
rather than you know opting out of 12 if
you unknown bad which means that if any
future you know configuration to get
launched like when Google TV launch we
introduce new TV DPI for example your
apps wouldn't show up for anything like
that so just be very aware of what
you're doing when you use this it's not
London Street but that is currently the
only way you can even hide your app in
market motor that aren't you a person
it's nothing you're welcome well another
thing my joy with the tablet you can do
you not to say Imogen sleep or so you
don't either based on android buildings
nervously on his own little tablets so
that'll cover love screams and it's not
based on screen size not necessarily
because what about ice cream sandwich
phones I mean they're going to be
greater than the APK devil than the sdk
level right and they're still gonna be
on smaller things you're gonna get you
know this small any ericsson phone and
so on running running ice cream sandwich
right now there's no I'm ready bastard
this is nothing saying it has to be as
hdpi either could could be a normal DPI
normal spies and still be ice cream
sandwich
christmann from Warren looking for a
replacement of using toast to perform a
floating message Nora is toast because
when the home screen keeps it for I'll
you're going to find this missing an
easy solution and display a display a
dialogue activity with a timeout on it
how about a frame layout with a just
attack you gotta go and you asian
flexible now I see I see no reason why
you couldn't just put you put a little
timer the alarm manager or a little
thread or something to just watch the
time and make it go away at the right
time that's been joined by Yosi row
welcome to the dead do you do you want
to ask this question or do you have one
anyone we are Ritter already and you'll
tell oh no asking lifting just wanted to
see how you're answering the questions
already long as I'm on the return thank
you make sure we're not missing will be
a question what is the best software
tool to display the phone screen or
tablet on the computer screen I've seen
some some Google presentations of some
phone screens on the big screen demo
well when you see a Google presentation
more often than not you're probably
actually seeing the hardware video out
the hdmi out driving the display
directly but if you want to do an
entirely in a software solution in the
past we've been in hands of the utility
called droid apps screen the URL is blog
rival nation com
troi dat screen it's a nice I think
that's a pretty nice utility for
explains the the video on software and
um and it's free so you know it's worth
more than your paperwork I think I got a
good example it with the emulator
getting hardware acceleration photo
rendering and the hacks emulators well
in the Intel slot the index is getting
much more performance so if you all
wanted to record videos and certain
things like the emulators actually
getting the viable alternative that's
pretty cool I remember the first time I
tried to demo a honeycomb in the
emulator in front of a live audience oh
yeah I probably should have gone with a
smaller than this smaller than HD screen
resolution really so Lauren says he's
using HDMI need to do my report card
cool it's a good solution yeah well if
you're using ice cream sandwich device
as well you can go into the settings
developer options and turn on show
touches which is a nice way to report a
video showing where you are actually
touching this week so let's see let's
whistle muttering what is the best way
to give access nothing but it was
probably my mom's in bitch no good is
there a proper way to use search recent
suggestions provided with a part of the
text you I don't know you know anybody
done surgeries and suggestions provided
I I would say try stack over book yeah
I've not tried again to
little obscure when I I looked into this
a little bit but didn't didn't come up
with a really good answer so I will
acknowledge the question and all Joyce
not having an answer for you in this
comment Bernie asks about any chance of
making it under component for a war
looks like a rotating wheel control on
iOS I'd say not very big chance no and
problem being that I think there is a
tendency to not want to row the standard
patrol kick because of the legacy that
involves them at work that involves like
you know maintaining it forever and
making sure it's back up at school and
so and so forth I think we've seen more
of a tendency of the annual team to
introduce new functionality into exactly
that support library so things like view
pager for example losing support library
Robin official you I forget ah i thinks
of those reasons were not having to
commit ourselves to maintaining it for
forever and ever and so i can't see it
becoming a standard talk it I saw would
we bought it like if it's pretty neat
you can see that way it sounds like a
great great community effort but then I
had a quick glance at the iOS page and
it looked like it was you know
completely spelt out how to go about it
it sounds like a fun project it for that
kind of operation to run boy don't see
any reason why you won't be able to go
through that or you know trying to get
some people to help you out sign up and
I sorta project that there is already a
radial menu widget project on google co
which may be a great starting point and
is going to pop a link up so that they
can have a look and see whether it's
enough for them to get going with oh
well i like that speaking at radial menu
i also love the I love that they hidden
they hidden real button labs feature in
the browser in honeycomb and beyond
that's my that's my preferred UI for the
road
to see there's a question in the chat
here drew Bryce wants to know when
dealing with PDFs it can't be open in
app using a browser windows their
particular PDF SDK we would recommend to
people like as as a compiled in library
I don't know I mean there are some but I
don't have any reason to prefer one over
the other I would you know I think
you're you're you're basically your
option ears to just install an app that
reads PD case and send an intent does no
justice do any of the Google provided
apps on Android VT k an AOS paper and
many realms like a from carries convoy
simple you know okay view it or
something like that the other day I
doctoring even though sir this it's
possible to pick up how many packages
can serve this a certain in 10 so it
might be worth putting into the code to
check to see if there is anything that
can service of you in 10 on a PDF and
there's nothing there maybe he wants to
pick a favorite application for a market
for viewing PDFs and pop up the
recommendation that they install it from
market and send the appropriate link to
the package that they want installed
right in fact there's a there's a neat
little snippet of code i think it's
yummy you Vivien Leigh in the resources
part of of developer android com I think
it's called can I send this intent that
gives you the code that queries a
package much to see who and who can
service the antenna we can we can now I
can look to that at some other time if
we don't get it by the end of the hall
you see we have they would know if any
of the media apps out there do support
any extras for doing things like such
such a highlighting sex then we've got
an experience that I'm using ezpdf I
think that one has some song like
integration with the web and sorry
internal text searching also went
searching but you know you can enjoy
that with improve the exit the extra
wood you can eat no no I just know that
at the time when I select a PDF file it
mother I'm looking to the community we
had a question I'm tired liar I don't
think is known in the chat right now
said call you they start my get
resources using the NDK now there isn't
a lot of documentation on this um there
is some discussion and if you use her
stack overflow for it for instance stack
overflow questions 265 18 16 or stack
overflow questions 2278 359 there's some
discussion or links to other discussions
about how to get resources into your NDK
code and they basically involve a hacks
that let you essentially read your ad
cave directly using the C code and
extracting your resources out of it from
there I think through 2.3 m was isn't
there an official asset manager that
lets you get access to the ethics then
that's assets but I think we're talking
specifically about resources the do
these I thought I mean I think these are
different things right but yes getting
getting app getting access to your
assets is another equally interesting
and equally valid question
and that one is a little more visually
supported all you have to do is link to
the asset manager and there's some I
think there is some sample code in the
NDK samples that shows that Oh excellent
I'll find the link to our question about
attention filters inside bar the chap
let's see nobody else in the Hangout
Nick you have any more questions from
the clustering I'm here is checking ok
all around in the next three which I am
NOT on think that in the answer of but
maybe you guys do apparently set on our
throats completed listener in the Texas
big package has been deprecated as a API
a level 15 will this brake application
50 written with that method or there'll
be some backwards compatibility I don't
probably know the answer any energy
budget use this that people know
anything about being a fitted not use it
I mean generally never occasion has kind
of a long tail you know when we'd ever
get something it means we plan to drive
support for it but we don't say when I
mean you look at like say we lay out
Phil apparent that's the deprecated
since lady I seven and we're still or
still longing to use it so yeah who is
was to say I think that the the
framework team does their best not to
drop any you know not to drop anything
that applications depend on without
providing a valid you know useful
replacement part so we've just been
joined by just had a quick look in the
documentation it says as a set on
utterance progress listener which should
be used instead of set or nutter ins
completed listener ok so answer a pop
the link up in the Google+ comments so
the
the question asker can refer to that
which versions is that so the true
leases of that supported that is 15
onwards sir looks like it's just an API
rename to handle progress all the way
through rather than just having a single
completed listener it's unconditional
code to check what is joining and pull
the right thing hmm I wonder if this is
I wonder if this is in order to support
a continuous mode recognition or
something like that yeah the progress
one this supports three methods I'm done
on their own on start rather than just
hated to just seemed like a better
solution I guess it's quite clear
switchover it isn't it really so
depending on year you can either wrap
your and your Cove in checking the oh I
stopper version see what version you're
running on yeah and invoke the right one
the platform is running the pond like
progressive enhancement and but like a
likes Bucky says districts def Gators
and it's going to go away anytime real
soon we don't want to go and break your
budget battle there so I say any new
code google writing or if you have it's
not so they all go get easy then then do
but yeah keep lying it to see what after
by the way so we've been joined and hang
out by is your name in water so you win
looking at that right did you want to
ask the question of an Android
development
not saying are you muted well we'll give
you a minute to get sorted then I have a
question a moderator is there any way to
include resources in the jar of a
library project if not does that mean I
did if I have custom resources the only
react to the studio libraries by sending
the whole project place the short answer
is it's not supported at this time to
include resources in the jar of a
library project so I don't know I don't
know what our plans would be for doing
that in teacher that I think there's
nothing wrong okay be stable even with a
moderator question so I have a counter
which is running indefinitely on an
activity I want to get current value of
the counter in each moment when I
switched to another activity weapon
under seat um well I would say this is
this is a great activity lifecycle
question at the time when you switch
from your first activity to the second
activity your first activities receive
is going to have its on plasma that
called and during on pause you can grab
the value of that Connor included in
shared resource and then your your next
activity can read that resourcing and
get the value of that how's that sound
events I didn't quite understand the
question now really let's they want to
be able to access its counted from
different activities well the experts
say it it says it says I want to get a
current value of the counter in each
moment when i switch to another activity
i took that as meaning outlets time on
the switch but maybe you're right link
he wants it always he went because it
has been nice early i thought one
possibility might be to do the mounting
in a service actually let multiply
tippity gonna bind to service in order
to gather paranoid but I didn't fight
and son
to enter to the Western depending on
what the what the asker's intent was the
other thing is if face explicitly
switching to the other activity is false
already alone in a bundle search for
bundle it in the antenna have to so many
good ways to do it lincoln irvine says i
find the new clips logcat to be written
in flexible to use for example i can
select copy portions of what's given one
may also find that it you try to look at
something while it's still scrolling
introspect a lot and he wants to know
how many of you prefer to view your log
cats and eclipse versus using adb logcat
an internal well i can enter that i
always do it in eclipse I just I try to
look sharp and use I try to use the
built-in the filtering functions to
filter only messages for my application
same here i can never remember the CLI
syntax foreign filtering when I still
tired of using eclipse although there
are some cool scripts are there which
will give you like funky highlighting
dear look out I tend to go with a
command line one because i tend to pipe
it through other commands like brett for
doing filtering and sometimes dump it to
a file as the logs being generated so
I've but I've been using unix her for
too long yeah you know honestly all I
expected that answer hmmm you just you
just seem like a command line so the guy
I guess oh I come back from the days
when I Rick's was still a popular
operating system now I disputed the
claim that iris was ever part it was
amongst people who are rich enough to
own SGI boxes in the University
yeah now yeah we had we had some nice
ones too yeah the my personal iris yep
that's its claim to fame as it was the
only version of UNIX you couldn't
actually find them out of free disk
space in kilobytes it would only ever
tell you in blocks just think all the
way you can do it as using a velvety God
monitor that's also useful do you have
any more questions from participants
laying out same except stang had fun
with microphone but feel free to type in
your question in the chat if you have
one yeah okay well if you if you want to
take your question please feel free and
i'll go ahead and while you're typing on
i'll look at the next question who
moderator the normal way to convert the
dot 3gp file created using me your word
into doc wav file format the best answer
we came up with that is ffmpeg you say
you turn that off device well the aspera
didn't say spoke yet to the way we felt
like answering another question does
android browser web use for https on
other parts besides 443 i assume that it
does right out if it doesn't it doesn't
but i assume it does hey does anyone
have any any last questions before we
wrap it up for the weak ones once in
typing activity i don't know if i'm home
typist 20s was questioned about okay
woman but you can always ask it in the
moderator thread
we will answer it as soon as we can and
and possibly discuss it in my hand one
next week where you can ask your
question on Stack Overflow and and let
us know billing to stack overflow and
then you will have the benefit of the
entire global Android developer
conspiracy lending their wisdom to to
your programming challenges